it's known as america's best idea and
where the west begins yellowstone
national park is celebrating its
150th anniversary this year joining us
to talk about how the very first
national park is marking the occasion
executive director of wyoming office and
tourism diane schober and native
american artist robert martinez thank
you both so much for joining us this
morning i see you standing there at the
old faithful inn right by the famous
geyser
talk about why yellowstone is such a
special place
well yellowstone is special in so many
ways especially because of its landscape
the geothermal features the wildlife
that could be experienced here but it
really is about the people that have
been protecting and taking care of these
special lands even long before the
150 years ago when yellowstone was
designated as america's first national
park and really started a movement for
designations of parks around the world
national parks around the world
and it is it is lovely i've had the
pleasure of visiting once it's a
fantastic ecosystem
rich native american history and culture
there
art everywhere it survived wildfires
reintroducing the gray wolf
robert talk about the art event that's
happening to celebrate the park well i'm
a northern rappo and chicano and i'm one
of six artists from around the country
that are currently showing here at the
old faithful inn
at the native art market
featuring imagery and creations from our
historical cultures but also uh speaking
on some of the native issues of today
you know there seems to be a renewed
romance and renaissance though with the
american west in general cowboys native
american culture uh where you can still
experience it all and and why do you
think that is diane what's going on
well you know there's always been uh the
world has had a love affair with the
american west i think there's something
that is in the spirit of all of us uh an
independence but yet a sense of
adventure
and and that has been a long driving
force for why people would want to visit
wyoming but then you have an
entertainment and pop culture today
a lot of
resurgence of western content and that
really has sparked a lot more interest
and
we know that if you're interested in
that that you can come to wyoming and
wyoming will deliver on that for you an
experience for the real west right here
in wyoming tell us how people can
celebrate the 150th birthday
well you can log on to travelwyoming.com
and you'll see right away the 150 years
of inspiration and that will link you to
a variety of activities that are
happening through the national park
service here in yellowstone but also
links to artists like robert and you can
find a beautiful commemorative poster
that he did specifically for this
particular commemoration but all of your
trip planning resources would be
available for you right at
travelwyoming.com
[Music]